l'art s'invite de plus en plus sur les
tablettes des épiceries une façon pour
les compagnies de se démarquer par des
étiquettes très esthétiques parfois même
signé par des artistes reconnus
ces jolies sacs colorés ne contiennent
pas de bonbons car j'ai amené ça comme
idée dans un meeting avec les autres
associés et on veut je veux mettre du
café là dedans tout le monde
rit de moi épuré coloré ou olé olé l'art
s'invite de plus en plus sur les
produits alimentaires c'est un peu un
rapport de séduction les emballages plus
graphisent donc ça fait faire la
première vente
peintre illustrateur ou graphiste
dispose et exposent sur les tablettes
d'épicerie
il y avait personne qui voyait le sac de
café comme un objet tu vois mais
simplement juste comme un contenant de
café quand on consommateur se promène
dans l'épicerie il est interpellé par
environ 300 000 produits en moyenne donc
l'emballage doit absolument attirer
l'attention l'arrêter dans sa course et
lui faire une promesse des boutiques des
supermarchés et même des dépanneurs où
on peut flâner des arts sans s'ennuyer
presque comme dans une galerie d'art par
où on s'en va quelque chose de simple
comme ça microbrasser Robin quand on
parle de minimalisme ici le fait d'avoir
une étiquette blanche laissez la page
blanche en fait avec une jolie
illustration toute simple en fait on
fait confiance à l'espace on donne de
l'espace au visuel et puis on fait
confiance à la marque au point de
l'écrit très petite
le monde de la biasse c'est quelque
chose qui parmi ce que de plus éclaté
présentement au niveau de l'étiquetage
quelqu'un qui décide de s'aventurer tout
seul là-dedans ça se pourrait qu'il
décide de prendre la plus belle il y a
quelques années des fois on avait
toujours l'impression que les brasseurs
faisaient affaires avec leur cousins qui
avaient des bases en Photoshop
aujourd'hui on voit notamment dans le
domaine de la bière l'illustrateur et
roi je dirais les brasseries ontariennes
dans l'Ouest aussi je vois beaucoup de
trucs éclatés des fois que je peux avoir
en échangeant avec des clients qui me
ramènent des petits trésors je pense que
le talent est à grandeur du Canada dans
les années 80 les microbrasseries ce
qu'on appelait à l'époque des
microbrasseries mais qui sont
aujourd'hui des grosses brasseries comme
boréales comme une hibrou mais ils ont
commencé à sortir à vouloir raconter des
histoires parce que c'est un peu ça on
veut raconter des histoires on veut
rattacher une histoire à notre produit
donc il y a des artistes qui ont presque
émergé grâce aux alcools québécois je
pense qu'il y en a qui vivent de ça
absolument qui vivent de leur art sur
les produits puis c'est quelque chose
qui est de plus en plus sollicité
une centaine de vignerons un peu partout
au Québec à la boîte à vin c'est à peu
près tout le monde qui ont changé leurs
étiquettes dans les cinq dernières
années pour justement s'ajuster un petit
peu au marché en développant une culture
alimentaire locale par exemple bon on a
commencé à trouver qu'on avait envie de
parler à nos gens avec un langage de
proximité avec un langage du Québec par
exemple plus local ça donne beaucoup de
diversité dans les produits versus une
époque ou peut-être on avait des
produits qui se ressemblaient tous un
peu avec une présentation suggéré un bol
de cuillère le produit alimentaire je
pense aux boîtes de conserve par exemple
les vins puissent on fait jazzy beaucoup
dès leur début alors qu'ils se sont
associés au peintre Marc Seguin pour
illustrer leur bouteilles peut-être
aujourd'hui encore le vin qui est le
plus en demande sur le marché ils ont
vraiment explosé eux sur les réseaux
sociaux donc à l'époque en fait il y a
cinq ou six ans on vendait pas vraiment
via Instagram ou et compagnie donc eux
vraiment il y avait une stratégie
Instagram donc du coup sur le parrain
qui était très très fort l'étiquette a
créé un engouement pour un vin que le
public n'avait pas encore goûté
j'ai vu aussi là on a même la signature
de l'artiste devant alors ça c'est
vraiment intéressant ils ont vraiment
mis le paquet là-dessus vignoble
fragments on a même pas le nom du
vignoble
uniquement sur l'étiquette
l'emballage peut faire une première
vente c'est sûr que ça garantit pas
nécessairement que le consommateur va
venir mais il y a une fidélisation qui
peut se faire à travers l'image puis un
plaisir aussi de l'objet donc l'objet
est pas seulement fonctionnel mais il y
a aussi esthétique
deux gars colorés qui débordent d'idées
et du café torréfié à Montréal voici ce
que ça donnait une gang de gens qui est
assez genre éclectique comme une espèce
de melting pot une bonne soupe avec
plein d'ingrédients à l'intérieur donc
on essaie que ça ça se transparaît dans
notre image de marque aussi loin des
sacs en papier brun la tendance des
beaux emballages et bien établie chez
les microsorifacteurs
une belle étiquette c'est sûr que c'est
très vendeur c'est un étagère mais si le
produit suit pas tu crées pas une base
de clients qui va revenir racheter ton
café peu importe comment c'est beau oui
un certain règles de reconnaissance mais
en termes techniques selon le produit à
part les règlements obligatoires comme
les tables nutritionnel les bars codés
et les ingrédients on est complètement
libre de notre espace graphique
est-ce qu'on est rendu à acheter pour le
look une bouteille de vin
est-ce qu'on est rasé
pas que ça aide par contre faut pas
ambitionner
on a le Stade olympique qui tient une
planche de skateboard cassée parce que
c'est un rebelle c'est chaussures là
c'est des Adidas qui ont été
conceptualisés pour les Jeux Olympiques
ça c'est un berlingo de mélasse et ce
design là il est pas moderne du tout il
est super vieux et il est super
classique mais il est intemporel
[Musique]
tartinade sauce chocolat leur
alimentaire s'expose maintenant partout
au Canada dans les pays anglo-saxons ou
la notion de marketing est très présente
on sent cette espèce d'énergie qui
continue et qui semble pas avoir de
frontières parce que là effectivement
quand on est rendu avec des cafés roses
il semble que tout est possible et
pourquoi pas